herrn seibert gestern so besprochen dass
wir glauben das ist ein auch in diesen
zeiten gerade in diesen zeiten ein
richtiges informationsforum aber sie
sehen auch die regierungspressekonferenz
verändert sich insoweit dass wir eine
andere sitzordnung haben wir halt einen
abstandsflächen sowie viele von uns das
an allen stellen tun wo menschen
zusammenkommen
wir haben die regeln für unsere
sitzordnung die wir ansonsten haben
nämlich nach der häufigkeit der
fragestellung in den vergangenen wochen
jetzt etwas abgeändert haben einfach mal
versucht zu antizipieren
an wen sich besonders viele fragen
richten könnten zum beispiel an das
bundesgesundheitsministerium die
sprecherinnen und sprecher dieser
ministerien sitzen jetzt hier vorne die
anderen danke dass sie auch da sind sind
jetzt locker in den saal verteilt und
wir müssen jetzt einfach mal
improvisieren üben wie das geht wenn die
wechselspiele sich vielleicht nicht so
einfach vollziehen können wie wir das
sonst tun ich glaube aber wir sammeln
jetzt auch mal erfahrungen
ich glaube es ist sinnvoll wenn wir
wechseln ich könnte jetzt natürlich
einfach auch in den saal die mikrofone
reinschalten aber das wäre
wahrscheinlich für die filme mit einem
kollegen schlecht also machen wir die
wechsel aber versuchen das dann
vielleicht ein bisschen zu sammeln aber
ich versuche das mal dass wir nicht
ständig hier ein hin und her haben die
veränderten regeln für die teilnahme an
der regierungsspitze oder an allen
pressekonferenzen bundespressekonferenz
haben wir den mitgliedern zugeschickt
sie haben sich am eingang registriert
damit wir dann im notfall personen
verfolgungsmaßnahmen einleiten können
so genug der vorrede ich glaube es gibt
keine vorab ankündigungen es gibt gleich
noch eine ankündigung vom
justizministerium aber ich glaube wir
nehmen erst mal die allgemeinen fragen
rein und drang naturgemäß mit dem thema
krone an
jung dann herr rinke bitte also es geht
vor allen dingen die laufenden die
grenzkontrollen würde ich ganz gerne
wissen welche einschränkungen gibt es
bei menden verkehr und welche einbußen
bei der wirtschaft sind zu erwarten
gegen möglichen schleppenden
warenverkehrs und of sale enthält
prognosen gibt und da die anderen auch
noch ganz viele fragen haben nur firma
moravek würde ich nachher gerne auch
noch mal fragen aber das sind jetzt mal
so viel deswegen und ich würde sagen wir
machen das jetzt so richten sie jetzt
primär die fragen an diejenigen die da
sind wenn wir wechseln kündigt sie das
irgendwie an und dann sagen wir die
fragen an diejenigen die dann nach vorne
kommen so das war als wahrscheinlich
wirtschaft und eine wirtschaft in bitte
ich muss jetzt ja auch was drücken
ich muss noch mal kurz nachfragen als
sie hatten gefragt werden auch aus
grenzkontrollen ja und welche
einschränkungen beim pendelverkehr
ok also wir haben ja gestern mit einer
pressemitteilung darüber informiert was
seit heute morgen 8 uhr umgesetzt wird
das heißt also an den binnengrenzen zu
österreich der schweiz frankreich
luxemburg und dänemark wird seit heute
morgen 8 uhr kontrolliert durch die
bundespolizei und diese kontrollen
finden statt mit der zielrichtung dass
die eindämmung durch die
infektionsgefahren die bestehen weiter
reduziert werden können und uns ist
dabei wichtig dass der warenverkehr und
der grenzüberschreitende verkehr von
berufspendlern davon nicht betroffen ist
genauso wird es derzeit umgesetzt
der präsident der bundespolizei hat
heute morgen auch den
bundesinnenminister über die ersten
erfahrungen unterrichtet und hat genau
diesen stand auch wieder gegeben ja ich
kann vielleicht weiter ergänzen wir
beobachten die situation jetzt es sind
ja vorübergehende kontrollen an den
binnengrenzen eingeführt worden und
wichtig wie der kollege gesagt hat dass
der bahnverkehr weiter erfolgen kann
auch berufspendler ausgenommen sind aber
quantifizierung kann ich jetzt im
augenblick nicht vornehmen
herr jung könnte vielleicht mal
grundsätzlich begründen warum die
grenzschließung verhältnismäßig ist und
notwendig ist also zunächst einmal ist
wichtig noch einmal hervorzuheben dass
wir keine grenze geschlossen haben das
ist ein begriff der schlicht in die irre
führt wir haben kontrollen angeordnet
das heißt die bundespolizei sichtet den
grenzüberschreitenden verkehr kommt auch
mit den menschen die das betrifft die
also in den kontrollen landen ins
gespräch und spricht über die frage ist
die reise die jetzt gerade
grenzüberschreitend stattfindet dringend
notwendig dringend notwendig ist der
warenverkehr dringend notwendig ist sehr
grenzüberschreitende verkehr von
berufspendlern aber dringend notwendig
sind beispielsweise nicht touristischer
verkehre wie nur sozusagen einem
vergnügungs ziel im benachbarten ausland
dienen die verhältnismäßigkeit ergibt
sich daraus dass wir an
unterschiedlichen stellen in europa wo
grenzverkehr auch in richtung
deutschland verlaufen krisenregionen aus
geworfen wurden und wir damit rechnen
müssen dass aus diesen krisenregionen
möglicherweise eine erhöhte
infektionsgefahr resultiert die dann
nach deutschland hinein getragen wird
es gibt sie im schengener grenzkodex
diese möglichkeit auch zur abwehr von
gefahren für die öffentliche gesundheit
maßnahmen zu ergreifen
das heißt also all das was derzeit
geschieht geschieht nicht außerhalb von
eu recht sondern im absoluten einklang
mit eu-recht diese fälle sind explizit
vorgesehen
zusätzlich ist die grenze für die
meisten geschlossen die eben keine güter
über die grenze bringen oder pendeln
müssen
das ist das ja korrekt und was ist mit
den grenzen zum beispiel nach tschechien
und polen ist es ist damit zu rechnen
davon auszugehen dass die jetzt nächstes
geschlossen müssen kontrolliert werden
also zunächst auch mal die grenze ist
nicht geschlossen gerade eben nicht für
pendler ist sie geschlossen sie ist
sozusagen ein einzelzimmer
im jeweiligen einzelfall wenn jemand aus
einem nicht triftigen grund reisen will
dann gibt es eine entscheidung die reise
beschränkt wirkt aus dieser jeweiligen
individuellen perspektive könnte man
sagen für mich ist die grenze zu aber
dieser absolute begriff grenzschließung
der trifft einfach in der sache nicht so
was polen und tschechien angeht das sind
eben genau diese verhältnismäßigkeit
überlegungen die stattfinden ist es ja
so dass die tschechische republik und
auch polen für sich schon entschieden
haben weitreichende beschränkungen des
reiseverkehrs einzuführen und auch haben
auch in beiden reise richtung das
verfügt und daraus resultierend sind wir
der auffassung dass es dazu im moment
jedenfalls keiner zusätzlichen anordnung
deutscher behörden bedarf denke dann
herr zweiter direkter anhalter es hat
eher ein paar fragen ergeben was das nun
für nichtdeutsche betrifft vielleicht
könnte ich das einfach noch mal ein
bisschen erklären was zum beispiel mit
der eu ausländern ist die an der grenze
sind hier in deutschland wohnen oder
deutschen partner haben oder ansonsten
partner haben und hier in deutschland
leben wie müssen die nachweisen dass sie
noch nicht auf touristischen besuchen
sind wer kann einen reisen wer nicht
anknüpfen
daran an frau adebar vielleicht können
sie uns bitte sagen haben sie einen
überblick wie viele deutsche sich im
moment im ausland befinden die zurück
wollen also sich möglicherweise an den
botschaften gemeldet haben es gibt ja
einschränkungen beim flugverkehr und an
das wirtschaftsministerium auch in
diesem zusammenhang mit diesen
grenzkontrollen die frage ob sie den
überblick haben wo der warenverkehr
tatsächlich eingeschränkt ist denn es
gibt ja berichte über kilometerlange
schlangen die jetzt nicht an der
deutschen grenze zumindest es aber
zwischen österreich in italien sind die
ja die logistik und das weitere arbeiten
auch von deutschen firmen belastet ja
also zunächst einmal ist diese
wiedereinführung von grenzkontrollen und
auch die entsprechenden konsequenzen aus
diesen kontrollen nicht an bestimmte
staatsangehörigkeiten geknüpft sondern
an die frage ob der reisezweck der
vorgetragen wird
nach prüfung und auch nach einschätzung
der grenzbehörde triftig ist also
dringend notwendig ist
das kann man schlecht pauschal festlegen
in welchen fällen das geld
gegeben ist wir haben eine festlegung
für den warenverkehr für den berufs
pendelverkehr erlassen aber es mag
andere gründe geben die aus persönlichen
schwerwiegenden gründen dennoch dringend
sind und eben keine berufs pendelfahrten
sind das muss im jeweiligen einzelfall
im pflichtgemäßen ermessen durch die
bundespolizei dann bewertet werden
es ist ja so dass das für die
bundespolizei keine gänzlich neue
aufgabe ist das ist im grunde genommen
bei der durchführung von grenzkontrollen
etwa an dem internationalen flughäfen
ein kernelement jeder einreisekontrolle
dass der einreise zweck plausibilisiert
werden muss das heißt also die
bundespolizei ist ja keineswegs auf
neuem terrain unterwegs und die frage
nach den eu bürger und und schritt und
tritt staatsangehörigen ist auch so zu
beantworten dass es alle personengruppen
treffen kann die grenzüberschreitend
weisen mit einer ausnahme deutschen
staatsangehörigen kann die einreise nach
deutschland verhindert verweigert werden
die werden immer einreisen können aber
eu bürger müssen damit rechnen dass die
reisebeschränkungen auferlegt bekommen
es sei denn sie haben sozusagen
eindringenden reisegrund und das gleiche
gilt auch für drittstaatsangehörige
ungeachtet der frage ob sie in
deutschland einen aufenthaltstitel
besitzen oder visumfrei reisen sowie
zwei andere frage aber wir haben noch
keine gesamtzahl wie viel deutsche
weltweit im moment noch auf reisen sind
und nach deutschland zurückkehren wollen
und von den internationalen
beeinträchtigungen im flugverkehr
betroffen sind wir müssen aber davon
ausgehen dass es doch mehrere tausend
deutsche sein könnten wir sammeln das
gerade und sind in einem intensiven
kontakt mit reiseveranstaltern mit
fluglinien in den einzelnen ländern um
zu schauen welches die besten
rückreisemöglichkeiten zunächst auf
kommerziellem wege für deutsche urlauber
die im ausland sind gestrandet sind auch
sind und bemühen uns damit hochdruck wir
unsere konsulate und botschaften
um möglichst pragmatische und auch
möglichst schnelle lösung
in diesem zusammenhang auch noch mal von
mir die information noch mal verstärken
dass wir seit dem wochenende weltweit
von allen nicht notwendigen und das sind
touristische reisen die sind nicht
notwendig im moment abraten
wir sehen eben in den letzten tagen und
wochen das wegen des corona virus
weltweit und auch in deutschland
einreise und ausreise beschränkungen
immer mehr ausgesprochen werden und
flugverbindungen reduziert oder
eingestellt werden wenn ein land sagt
deutsche sollen bei uns nicht mehr
einreisen heißt das natürlich erstmal
man solle nicht dort einen reichen aber
es hat auch wieder rückwirkung auf den
flugverkehr da aus dem land heraus geht
und dann eben auch wieder auf die
rückreise
insofern ist es unser dringender appell
nicht notwendige reisen ins ausland im
moment zu unterlassen für die deutschen
die im ausland sind sind wir mit
hochdruck daran lösungen zu erarbeiten
wenn sie nach deutschland zurückkommen
dann beantworte ich noch die frage zum
zum bahnverkehr
wie gesagt der warenverkehr kann weiter
stattfinden wir beobachten die situation
sehr genau wir können nicht ausschließen
dass es vorübergehend zeitverzögerung an
grenzen gibt aber die bundespolizei
hatte ja auch erklärt dass sie sehr
lebensnah möglichkeiten und kontrollen
insgesamt an den grenzen versuchen und
alle da das bestmögliche tun um
einschränkungen auf ein minimum zu
begrenzen um das ist das was alle
zusammen und gemeinsam versuchen
kurz danach fahren sie haben keine
meldung dass es an bestimmten grenzen
wirklich ernsthafte probleme gibt also
gestern war einmal die sprache davon
dass es staus von bis zu 50 kilometer
länger gibt
aktuell haben wir das nicht aber wie
gesagt wir können nicht ausschließen
dass es da vorübergehende
zeitverzögerung geben kann
mehr kann ich aber aktuell nicht dazu
sagen herr 2
ja genau dazu meine nachfragen clans bmi
wie ist das dann in der praxis werden
die lkws warenverkehr als weiterer
werden die dann gar nicht kontrolliert
oder
die stichprobenartig kontrolliert auf
die sind ja auch mal lkw fahrer die von
portugal nach russland fahren sind ja
potenzielle überträger von des virus und
können sie was sagen ist das personal
der bundespolizei da aufgestockt worden
oder gibt es da hängt passe ja also zur
ersten frage das ist je nach
grenzkontrollstelle möglicherweise
unterschiedlich es erfolgt
verhältnismäßig und die klare
zielrichtung des bundesinnenministers
der gesamten bundesregierung ist dass
der warenverkehr eben gewährleistet ist
und nicht durch kontrollen zum erliegen
kommt insofern kann ich mir gut
vorstellen aber das kann ich nicht für
alle jetzt für alle fans kontrollstellen
pauschalisieren dass wir den
personenverkehr stärker im blick haben
als den warenverkehr und die zweite
frage es ist so dass die dienststellen
die ohnehin im grenzraum ihren
zuständigkeitsbereich haben und für die
kontrollen zuständig sind jedenfalls bis
heute durch allein durch sieben
einsatzhundertschaften der
bundesbereitschaftspolizei verstärkt
wurden und eine technische
einsatzhundertschaft das heißt also wir
haben einen personalbestand der generell
an der grenze tätig ist der heute stand
jetzt schon um 700 pvb erhöht wurde die
gesamtzahl der eingesetzten
polizeibeamten habe ich jetzt nicht
verfügbar
kurze nachfrage wie sieht das aus mit
transit lkw sage mal die einfach nur
durch deutschland rollen beispielsweise
aus italien österreich kommen gibt es da
besondere maßnahmen oder dürfen die
einfach durchfahren und kontrolliert
naja es gilt eben dasselbe prinzip was
für alle gilt es geht darum dringend
notwendige reisen zu ermöglichen
insbesondere im warenverkehr und es gibt
da ja ganz vielfältige konstellationen
so dass man jetzt nicht pauschal sagen
kann ein transit lkw darf nicht mehr
erfahren das kommt ja darauf an zu
welchem zweck findet der transit stadt
soll vielleicht irgendwo waren
aufgenommen werden die woanders hin
transportiert werden müssen also die
gewährleistung der lieferkette so habe
ich das gestern verstanden ist ein
wichtiges element das wir gewährleisten
wollen und insofern gilt dieses prinzip
selbstverständlich auch da kämen dann
herr leithäuser
ich habe eine nachfrage eine frau adebar
ich kann mir das noch nicht richtig
vorstellen erklären sie uns mal was es
denn die grundlage ab wann ist ein
rückreise wunsch von deutschen touristen
ein fall für das auswärtige amt das ist
die fehlende flugverbindung ist es die
die ärztliche versorgung im land wo sie
sich aufhalten sind es die bestimmungen
in dem gastland die werden ja in dem
sinne jetzt nicht rausgeschmissen die
touristen wie wie sortieren sie das und
was wir spielräume haben sie dann wenn
sie sagen sie sind den absprachen mit
den reiseveranstaltern und ein drittes
gibt es da regionale schwerpunkte die
ihnen da besonders sorge machen und dann
hätte ich noch eine frage ans bmvg aber
ich weiß nicht ob wir wechseln also wie
das mit dem wechsel ist hab ich nicht
ganz mit ihrem ja improvisieren ja
manchmal gleich mal ja wir sehen wäre
froh wenn ich das sehe mehrere fragen
als wmv geht dann machen wir gleich noch
ein wechsel umstellen wie also ich
mutiere dass ich kann auch gerne
wechseln
erstmals war für adebar gefragt wir
sehen im moment regionale schwerpunkte
das sind marokko das ist die türkei
das sind länder wie die philippinen und
indonesien in asien
wann ist es ein fall für uns also für
uns ist es ein fall dass wir nach § 5
konsulargesetz für die hilfe für
deutsche im ausland grundsätzlich
zuständig sind
das heißt wir sind und dafür sind wir da
und das ist unser job
ansprechpartner für alle deutschen die
im ausland in eine wie auch immer
geartete notsituationen kommen die dann
konkret unsere hilfe nach dem
konsulargesetz aussieht richtet sich und
das muss sie glaube ich tun
nach den jeweiligen individuellen
umständen das heißt das kann von einer
ganz konkreten spezifischen hilfe in
einem medizinischen notfall bis hin zu
einer beratung gehen oder einer
kontaktaufnahme und im moment sehen wir
einfach dass viele deutsche im urlaub
gestrandet sind weltweit dass ihre
rückflüge storniert worden oder im
moment nicht stattfinden dass die
fluggesellschaften sich bemühen dort um
zu planen wir selbst sind natürlich mit
lufthansa und anderen fluggesellschaften
im gespräch
und wir versuchen einfach für die
deutschen die im ausland befindlich sind
lösungen zu finden die jeweils passen
und individuell für einzelne gruppen
womöglich sind wie man nach deutschland
zurückkehren kann alles im rahmen
unserer konsularischen beratung wenn es
dazu konkretere sachen noch gibt das
sind jetzt im moment beratung die wir
führen dann wäre mir das sofort
mitteilen und natürlich auch sofort den
betroffenen mitteilen wie gesagt da gibt
es eine ganz breite bandbreite dessen
was wir da ins auge fassen und annehmen
und das ist eine sehr fluide situation
sie müssen auch sehen dass wir
hunderttausende deutsche im ausland
haben nicht nur als touristen sondern
auch noch zum teil geschäftsreisende für
firmen im ausland unterwegs sind oder
menschen die mit ausländischen
ehepartnern teilweise oder ganz vor ort
leben und für viele dieser menschen wird
sich perspektivisch die frage aufstellen
wollen sie nach deutschland zurückkommt
für die kommende zeit oder bleiben sie
dort wo sie sind das heißt die touristen
sind eine gruppe die akute aber wir sind
natürlich auch mit ganz vielen anderen
deutschen die im ausland sind jetzt
verstärkt im gespräch oder sie treten an
uns heran
dann kann man auch jetzt die frau ganz
verteidigungsminister stellen das
verteidigungsministerium der wüsste ich
gerne zwei dinge zum einen was den
aufruf an die reservisten angeht sich in
krankenhäusern der bundeswehr zu melden
wenn sie ein bisschen erläutern würden
was der hintergrund ist was für aufgaben
anstehen ob die qualifiziert sein müssen
wie groß schon die ersten reaktionen auf
diesen aufruf hin sind und das andere
mal einen blick auf die großübung
defender auch da gab es ja nachrichten
in bezug auf einen abflug seine
konkreten teil dieser großübung was die
bundeswehr angeht der deutsche
perspektive aber sicher auch ein blick
und ein paar aussagen über die zahl und
die rolle der jetzt in europa
befindlichen amerikanischen soldaten was
machen die was passiert mit den schiffen
die voll sind nicht entladen werden
jetzt sagen wir vielleicht mal mit dem
zweiten punkt an us- defender ist ja ein
amerikanisch übung die wir mit host
nation support zunächst unter
das heißt die kräfte der us amerikaner
die sich in deutschland bewegen werden
durch uns logistisch unterstützt diese
übungs anteile sind soweit sie dennoch
stattgefunden haben
zunächst regulär zu ende geführt worden
das heißt die bewegungen der
amerikanischen kräfte sind zu orten
geführt worden wo sie danach auch
geordnet auch wieder zurückgeführt
werden können das ist der aktuelle
status
sie haben wir sicherlich die zahlen zur
kenntnis genommen dass insgesamt maximal
5500 us amerikanische soldatinnen und
soldaten
anders als zunächst geplant nur
deutschland betreten haben
mit dieser entscheidung ging
gleichzeitig einher die maßnahme dass
schiffe die sich auf dem weg nach
deutschland gefunden haben sofort
umgelenkt wurden also mit dem zeitpunkt
der entscheidung gab es keinen kräfte
aufwuchs mehr in europa für us defender
wir leisten seitens der bundeswehr
weiterhin die notwendige unterstützung
für die amerikanischen kräfte um sie
geordnet wieder nach hause zurück zu
führen also hoch nation support abgesagt
haben wir und das werden sie auch am
wochenende zur kenntnis genommen haben
alle aktiven übungs anteile es gibt
einige abschnitte dieser übung wo auch
deutsche kräfte bataillone kompanien auf
übungsplätzen mit den amerikanern
zusammen trainieren wollten diese
anteile sind komplett abgesagt worden
dann vielleicht zu der lage der reserve
dienstleistungen ich hatte ja am freitag
schon ausgeführt dass auf nachfrage was
darum gehen ob er jungen befürchten
müsste hier aktiv einberufen zu werden
als reserve dienst leisten da es nicht
so ist dass wir im moment in dem status
der der forderung ein genereller art und
weise uns befinden sondern ist dreht
sich darum dass unsere reserve
dienstleistenden angesprochen werden
angeschrieben werden ob sie in nächster
zeit die möglichkeit sehen freiwillig
die insbesondere die sanitätskräfte zu
unterstützen und hier geht es durch die
bank weg
ob es ärzte sind ob es pflegekräfte sind
ob es labor kräfte sind die werden alle
angesprochen und über das kommando
sanitätsdienst dann natürlich betreut
insbesondere geht es hier um
pflegefachkräfte für die intensivpflege
die krankenpflege aber auch
notfallsanitäter und
medizinisch-technische labor assistenten
werden gefragt
nochmal es ist durch die bank weg das
gesamte spektrum abgefragt und ich kann
ihnen standen heute morgen sagen dass
ein kommando sanitätsdienst derzeit 730
anfragen eingehen
davon können recht zeitnah etwa 380
reservistinnen und reservisten dann beim
sanitätsdienst der bundeswehr eingesetzt
werden kurze nachfrage zu der übung also
steht eine entscheidung über den abbruch
der gesamten übung an
und dann ist mir nicht ganz klar gewesen
diese 5000 us soldaten machen die sich
aus dem krieg oder muss auch darüber
erst noch entschieden werden
nach meiner kenntnis ist die
entscheidung seitens der amerikaner
gefallen jetzt geordnet diese übung zu
beenden von beendet können wir dann
natürlich erst sprechen wenn auch alle
kräfte deutschland verlassen meine frage
richtet sich ein vordenker und in frage
war zum einen würde ich gerne wissen ob
es irgendwelche bemühungen gibt nachdem
nun das schengen freizügigkeit regimes
so scheinbar unkontrolliert
zusammengebrochen und zwischen zu sein
scheint ein eingeordnete abstimmung zu
kreieren wann grenzkontrollen gelockert
werden oder bleibt es in nationaler
verantwortung und jeder macht seins und
das zweite betrifft die g7 runde heute
nachmittag gibt es irgendwelche weiteren
informationen über tagesordnung der
agenda was da besprochen werden also ich
kann ihnen berichten dass die kanzlerin
sich heute morgen mit dem
ratspräsidenten michelle der
kommissionspräsidentin von allein und
auch dem französischen staatspräsidenten
makro in einer video schalte
ausgetauscht hat über die aktuelle lage
das gemeinsame vorgehen besprochen hat
mit dem ziel die maßnahmen zu
vereinheitlichen um die
funktionsfähigkeit des binnenmarktes zu
wahren
also ich kann bestätigen dass die
bundeskanzlerin an einem der g7
besprechung der staats und
regierungschefs teilnehmen wird ich kann
den gesprächen hier jetzt nicht
vorgreifen das wird um 15 uhr
stattfinden
angesichts der ausbreitung des virus
liegt nahe dass völlig klar dass die
internationale zusammenarbeit von großer
bedeutung ist und da hat natürlich auch
die g7 eine zentrale rolle und eine
besondere verantwortung insofern nimmt
sie an diesem gipfel selbstverständlich
teil an dieser video-konferenz aber den
gesprächen kann ich nicht vorgreifen
alter kam dass dafür noch ergänzen
ich wollte noch zu ihrer ersten frage
ergänzen weise das sehr zugespitzt
formuliert haben natürlich hat auch am
vergangenen wochenende eine abstimmung
mit vielen partnern stattgefunden
insbesondere mit der europäischen
kommission auch mit frankreich mit mit
den staaten die von diesen maßnahmen
betroffen sind insofern ist es
keineswegs etwas was völlig unilateral
entschieden wurde
die kommission hat angekündigt dass sie
zeitnah leitlinien für diese maßnahmen
auch veröffentlichen wird aber sie
können davon ausgehen dass das was wir
jetzt für uns entschieden haben bereits
im geist dieser leitlinien stattfindet
insofern ist das schon ist eine
abstimmung schon vorher gelaufen
ich kann das von meiner seite aus
nochmal ergänzen und unterstützen auch
vonseiten des auswärtigen amtes ist mit
dem partner über das wochenende
kommuniziert worden und auch in brüssel
laufen da die fäden und die gespräche
zusammen um die europäische abstimmung
zu intensivieren
jetzt seid ihr die kollegen dort eine
frage ans verteidigungsministerium auch
dass du zwar noch und dann ist
verdunstet
ich habe eine frage an herrn platz ist
noch mal ergänzend zu der frage des
kollegen über die den aufruf bezüglich
der reservisten ist das was bisher in
der aktion reingekommen ist man liest
von über 700 reaktionen und die ihr
quasi sich gemeldet haben ist das für
sie eine größenordnung wie erwartet
irgendwie brauchen sie deutlich mehr
können sie etwas zu der zu den zahlen
sagen und wie sieht das selbst mit
koffer und dann bei der bundeswehr tauss
bei der bundeswehr aus zunächst zu den
reserve dienstleistenden eine
einschätzung da müssen sich tatsächlich
direkt an die sanitätsdienst wenden ich
kann ihnen aber sagen dass wir auch aus
der grund bewegung heraus derzeit
vollständig in der lage sind allen
anforderungen gerecht zu werden wir
bereiten uns nur perspektive straff vor
und das ist ja wohl auch angezeigt auch
höhere fallzahlen bearbeiten zu können
hier geht es auch im wesentlichen darum
dass wir die die arbeitsfähigkeit der
bundeswehr intern auch sicherstellen
denn wir müssen ja unser haupt aufträge
im rahmen der nationalen vorsorge eben
auch wahrnehmen aber eben dann natürlich
darüber hinaus kennt auch gerne alle
anderen kräfte staatlichen kräfte mit
unseren leistungen dann unterstützen
die zweite frage also auch hier sind die
zahlen natürlich stark im wandel
begriffen ich kann ihnen aber sagen dass
wir aktuell 25 verifizierte infektionen
haben und eine zahl von gründen
verdachtsfällen die sich knapp unter 200
derzeit aber wie gesagt das ändert sich
auch sehr schnell hat uns unterm fuß
noch mal nachfragen wie die entscheidung
zu den grenzschutz maßnahmen getroffen
ist herr villa hatte ja am vorigen
mittwoch gesagt grenzschutz maßnahmen
dieser art seien nicht die antwort auf
die herausforderung weil es völlig naiv
sein zu glauben dass das virus damit in
deutschland sich nicht weiter ausbreiten
können sie nochmal sagen warum herr
seehofer hat ja gestern auch in seiner
pressekonferenz darauf angesprochen dass
er sich über diese äußerung gewundert
hat das hat sich seit vergangenem
mittwoch verändert und wenn man sich die
maßnahmen in den anderen ländern
österreich italien spanien anschaut dass
man nur noch zur arbeit raus darf nur
noch zur apotheke usw können wir uns
darauf einstellen frau deanna dass das
auf deutschland auch zukommt und würden
sie empfehlen im vorbild bayerns mit der
ausrufung des katastrophenfalls zu
folgen also ich kann hier noch mal sagen
das wichtigste ist jetzt ja die
verbreitung des virus einzudämmen
und da kann ich nur noch mal auf die
dynamische lage der situation hinweisen
wie auf die verbreitung angemessen zu
reagieren ist lässt sich ja nicht alles
vorab auf das kleinste detail planen die
bundesregierung trust aber der lage und
dem rat der experten entsprechend
folgend ihre maßnahmen aktuell
fortlaufend an und insofern kann ich
jetzt auch nicht vorgreifen auf welche
maßnahmen da noch kommen könnten
aber wie gesagt die bundesregierung
passt ihre maßnahmen der lage und dem
rat der experten folgen und fortlaufend
an
ja also ich will vielleicht an dieser
stelle auch noch einmal an die erste
pressekonferenz erinnern die der
bundesinnenminister gemeinsam mit dem
gesundheitsminister hier zu diesem thema
abgehalten hat an dieser stelle und er
hat damals schon gesagt dass es eben
zwei wesentliche ziele gibt einmal die
ausbreitung die im lande zu verhindern
und andererseits aber auch dafür zu
sorgen durch geeignete maßnahmen das die
ausbreitung im grenzüberschreitenden
verkehr verändert
wird insofern war das von beginn an
seine grundsätzliche position wie das
dann immer so ist gibt es dann
abstimmungen und neue erkenntnisse das
findet ja fast täglich statt dass wir
etwas schlauer werden und die maßnahme
ist jetzt angeordnet worden und der
bundesligist hat auch gestern deutlich
gemacht das argument der virus sei
bereits in deutschland ist ja kein
argument dafür diese maßnahmen nicht
anzuordnen weil es natürlich darum geht
auch jetzt doch das menschenmögliche zu
tun um die ausbreitung zu reduzieren
ein macher ja können sie qualifizieren
die großen raum videokonferenzen bei
ihnen jetzt was internationale
absprachen betrifft eingenommen haben
ist das schon sagen wir mal bei verbot
gelockert worden mit ausrüstung ist
sichergestellt dass vor allem land haben
einige das waren jetzt zwei fragen ich
weiß auf jeden fall wenn eine lange
liste von fragen stellen
wir machen dann auch gleich noch eine
zweite runde also noch ein bisschen mehr
zeit als eine stunde
also ich kann ihnen das jetzt nicht
quantifizieren aber sie können ja
alleine aus dem was ich eben schon
vorgetragen habe schließen also heute
hat es eben die video konferenz gegeben
mit dem ratspräsidenten der
kommissionspräsident in dem
französischen präsidenten
es wird eine g7 seite geben also die
video konferenz wird sich großer
beliebtheit erfreuen
ja ich kann das für den außenminister
nur unterstützen da geht sehr sehr viel
auf video konferenz oder telefonschalten
über eigentlich fast alles auch zum
beispiel der sicherheitsrat in new york
überlegt wie man in diese richtung geht
die räte in brüssel gehen in diese
richtung der außenminister wird morgen
das vergaß sich anzukündigen
eine
video außen konferenz mit seinen
kollegen aus den baltischen staaten
estland lettland und litauen haben
da geht es um eine abstimmung der
politik deutschlands mit diesen
baltischen partnern und auch über corona
das wird wahrscheinlich eine zwei
stunden schalte werden eventuell
bekommen wir finden auch eine virtuelle
pressekonferenz das erste mal zu
organisieren also das sind technische
updates die wir jetzt alle ins auge
fassen und uns da täglich fortbilden um
an diese richtung besser gehen zu können
das bmwi
ja da kann ich gern zur stellung nehmen
beim thema schutzausrüstung muss man
zwei prozesse aktuell etwas
unterscheiden weil es auch da ständig
neue entwicklungen gibt es gibt eine
eine durchführungsverordnung auf eu
ebene die seit gestern in kraft getreten
ist und regelung und exporte an
drittstaaten unter die mit dem
genehmigungsvorbehalt der
mitgliedstaaten stellt und daneben
stehen nationale regelungen die wir
getroffen haben
es gibt dazu einen permanenten austausch
zwischen uns und der eu ebene um da auch
letzte offene fragen zu klären
aber es ist in der sache ist es ein
genehmigungsvorbehalt der in deutschland
durch das bundesamt für wirtschaft und
ausfuhrkontrolle das bafa kontrolliert
wird
und jetzt mache weiter tschuldigung eine
frage gibt noch mal einen alter eher
können sie noch einmal erläutern was das
für asylanträge an der grenze bedeutet
die beschränkungen an der grenze und
haben sie vielleicht auch eine zahl für
februar dabei weil die letzte die ich
gefunden habe bei diesem januar also in
welcher dimension wurde an der deutsch
österreichischen grenze noch asylanträge
gestellt und meine zweite frage da bin
ich mir nicht sicher wahrscheinlich geht
ihren ersten ans bier mal essen bisher
dass fachkräfte gesetz gerade erst in
kraft getreten wenn es da schon anträgen
gibt oder willigte abgeschlossener
arbeitsverträge wirken sich die grenz
maßnahmen darauf auch schon aus und
gerecht ist das ganze gesetz ins stocken
da würde mich meine einschätzung
interessieren
also ich wechsele munter alto verkauft
ich kann ja mal mit denen mit ihrer
ersten frage beginnen also ich habe
leider keine zahlen jetzt dabei wie
viele asylanträge an den grenzen
gestellt worden das müsste ich
nachliefern tue ich auch gern und
ansonsten ist es ebenso gerade jetzt
eine entscheidung getroffen gestern mit
zwei wesentlichen eckpunkten nämlich der
berufsverkehr muss gewährleistet sein
und der warenverkehr und ansonsten geht
es sozusagen um die abwägung liegt ein
dringender reisegrund vor und es gibt
eben unterschiedliche konstellationen
wie auch die von ihnen angesprochene
über die muss man noch reden
das findet auch weiterhin statt der
krisenstab wird sich mit all diesen
einzelfragen noch befassen aber ich kann
ihnen dazu im moment keine entscheidung
mitteilen
das ist noch nicht klar also die
antragsteller umgegangen wird
im moment gibt es da keine verfahren zur
veränderung im vergleich zu vorgestern
aber jetzt mal das thema antwortet und
wann sich die beiden kollegen rechts
dann weiß ich ja vielen dank vielleicht
möchte herr alter als federführendes
ressort zum fachkräfte
einwanderungsgesetz mich nachher noch
ergänzen
mir liegen darüber dass es zu stocken
kommt aktuell keine erkenntnisse vor
trotzdem spricht die lage natürlich in
gewisser weise für sich dass es da
schwieriger wird
was das angeht ich würde das
gegebenenfalls nach reichen falls ich da
noch eine konkrete informationen bekomme
ich gerne von von mir noch als ergänzung
die des gesetzes jahr seit 14 tagen
ungefähren kraft die botschaften und die
rechts und konsularabteilungen bemühen
sich den anreiseverkehr und auch die
visa antragstellung so gut es geht
weiter zu fahren
man kann auch sehr viel über eine
digitale plattform sich informieren und
inzwischen machen auch gerade für das
fachkräfte einwanderungsgesetz insofern
ist da der erste schritt auch hochgradig
digitalisiert wir haben die möglichkeit
geschaffen erstmal auch visa im inland
zu bearbeiten und dann mit dem das kann
es bmi gerne ergänzen mit den
ausländerbehörden darüber in kontakt zu
treten insofern tun wir da natürlich was
möglich ist um diese antragstellung
weiter ablaufen zu lassen
haben sie eine zahl wie viele anträge
liegen dabei den botschaften oder bei im
moment die habe ich nicht parat ich weiß
auch nicht ob es schon eine erste gibt
denn wie gesagt wir sind am tag 15 muss
man muss man schauen
ich denke das wird spätestens
monatsweise können wir das abrufen aber
vielleicht können wir es auch schon
jetzt hat jetzt sehen die frage an
ganz rein technisch vieler länder
einfach für sie selber entschieden haben
wie sie die grenzkontrollen für und in
polen zum beispiel der flugverkehr ist
komplett dicht viele leute versuchen zum
beispiel ausweichen und über zürich
fliegen was passiert mit einem
polnischen oder tschechischen
staatsbürger der versuch nach hause
über die grenze zum deutschland kommen
ob der kommt rein
oder er wird zurückgewiesen und die
zweite frage um pauschale reisen weil
viele deutsche reisebüros haben auch die
ausländischen kunden
und wenn zum weiteren beschränkungen
käme und die leute müssen zurückgeholt
werden werden die ausländischen staat
also die die andere staatsbürger elf aus
polen oder aus anderen ländern dürfen zb
dann nach berlin fliegen mit deutschen
reisebüro oder die werden auch nicht
rein
lassen wir die luft grenze dicht wird
also im moment ist ja der stand der dass
wir die grenzkontrollen auf dem landweg
angeordnet haben es wird sehr
wahrscheinlich auch überlegungen noch
geben in der bundesregierung wie mit
anderen verkehrswegen umzugehen ist
da kann ich im moment noch keine
einschätzung abgeben
aber ich habe das prinzip unserer
grenzkontrollen ja erläutert und man
muss immer dann auch die frage stellen
wenn dieser fall eintritt denen sie
skizziert haben gibt es andere
alternativen also ich gehe fest davon
aus dass das auch andere staaten so wie
wir das tun sich darüber gedanken machen
wie ihre eigenen staatsangehörigen
wieder nach hause kommen können
wir liegen da keine konkreten
informationen vor aber man muss schon
auch dann abwägen welche alternativen
gibt es noch ja gut aber sozusagen bin
ich in zürich ich will nach hause nach
polen nach stechen musste ich die grenze
passieren
bei der schrein unterlassen hat er sich
nicht eingelassen um transit nach polen
weiter zu führen
also nochmal ich bin jetzt hier der
sozusagen der sprecher des
bundesinnenministeriums es gibt eine
ganze vielzahl von möglichen
fallkonstellationen die ihn zum teil
auch schwierig zu entscheiden sind und
ich möchte jetzt hier nicht an dieser
stelle pauschal eine entscheidung für
für vergleichbare fallkonstellationen
bekannt geben das muss im rahmen der
grenzkontrolle verifiziert werden da
muss der einzelfall geprüft werden der
muss geprüft werden wie dringend ist die
reise heute gibt es alternativen
und dann kommt man zum ergebnis dass
müssen wir der bundespolizei überlassen
das können wir nicht pauschal und
zentral entscheiden
kollege hier dann herr meier dann drücke
ich habe ihren antworten nur noch eine
ganz kurze praktische frage frau dämme
haben sie im termin für morgen für die
video konferenz der bundeskanzlei mit
herrn mack und erdogan
mit denen habe ich nicht der urzeit also
ich hab keine uhrzeit aber das wird
morgen nachmittag statt
herr meyer der schalker ich habe eine
frage an das bmf
und ich denke mal das baby kann sie aber
nicht mal von bmi an wenn sie mir sagen
wie der sachstand ist in das baby sein
der sachstand ist im fall der bonner
firma impfstoff firma pure weg und gab
es tatsächlich anfragen aus der
us-regierung diese formation zu nehmen
ich glaube das macht meine kollegin aus
dem leben wegen jetzt wird munter
gewechselt
vielleicht könnte auch schon das
finanzministerium verteidigung wechseln
ich habe ganz viele fragen notiert aber
ich mache jetzt alle erstmal erstmal
dran sind und dann kommt die zweite
frage und das gefährlichste ist sehr
sehr lang zum thema kilo weg um die
kollegen wenn sie denn wollen gerne auch
noch ergänzen und zunächst aus sicht des
bundeswirtschaftsministeriums hat sich
der bundeswirtschaftsminister gestern im
bericht aus berlin ja zum thema auch
geäußert die bundesregierung hat
natürlich ein hohes interesse daran dass
wirkstoffe und impfstoffe in deutschland
und europa produziert werden dazu gibt
es auch einen sehr engen austausch
innerhalb der bundesregierung mit den
betroffenen ressorts und was konkret die
firma koubek angibt gab es ja gestern
eine äußerung der unternehmensleitung
die klargestellt hat dass für sie eine
exklusivität verkauf in richtung usa
nicht zur debatte steht dieser
ankündigungen äußerungen haben wir sehr
begrüßt
der bundeswirtschaftsminister hat gesagt
im stoff entwicklungen müssen natürlich
vorangetrieben werden aber sie müssen
für alle verfügbar sein
und das kann ja nicht um exklusivitäten
gehen und das ist unsere haltung
gab es diese versuche von der
us-regierung die firma zu übernehmen
das kann ich ihnen so nicht sagen es
gibt auch über medienberichte
es gibt einen austausch innerhalb der
bundesregierung auch mit dem unternehmen
aber ob ich das bestätigen kann oder
nicht dass dazu habe ich aktuell keine
ausreichende informationen das
beantworten
sodann war das finale
wenn sie fragen wir mal wiederholt ja
ich habe noch gar nicht gestellt
bayern setzt geschult haben sie aus wie
verhält sich der bund der minister hat
er zusammen mit seinem kollegen jan
altmaier
unser programm vorgestellt wie jetzt
weiter mit der krise umgegangen werden
soll
der anfängliche maßnahmen vorgestellt
weiteres wird sicherlich zu erörtern
sein wir werden jetzt auch in der in
dieser woche den haushalt und die
finanzplanung für die kommenden jahre
vorstellen
und da wird sich der minister auch zu
einem weiteren äußern grundsätzlich kann
ich schon mal sagen in der
schuldenbremse sind ja auch bestimmte
bestimmte punkte vorgesehen wenn die
konjunktur einbricht und auch wenn
unvorhergesehene notfälle eintreten
das kann ich zum jetzigen zeitpunkt dazu
sagen sollte und dann gehen wir in den
letzten reihe folgt zunächst ich habe
zwei große fragen das innenministerium
und dann noch zwei kurze fragen denn das
gesundheitsministerium da müssen wir
vielleicht schon wird es auch weitere
fragen ans finanzministerium geben und
dann überblick
dann wechselt war an der stelle und der
wahl kann das im bisherigen antworten ja
ganz nur eine frage von ihnen oder von
wem er hat die ziehen wir dann vor und
machen dann im wechsel das einfacher
also dann zunächst ihre frage an sie zu
den grenzen was ist denn der alte mit
den ganzen kleinen grenze dagegen es
gibt dutzende wenn nicht hunderte neben
der autobahn zum beispiel zwischen
deutschland und österreich werde auch
kontrolliert und er versucht zu
kontrollieren zwei grenzfrage haben sie
schon drei weise beantwortet sehe ich
das richtig dass im moment an den
flughäfen gar nicht kontrolliert wer hat
also zum beispiel innerhalb des
schengenraums von portugal wenn jemand
mit dem flugzeug kommt oder spanien er
wird nicht kontrolliert
ja ich fange mal von hinten an also die
zweite frage ja das ist richtig unsere
anordnung klage bezieht sich momentan
auf die landgrenzen zu den
angesprochenen ländern
das heißt betroffen sind alle
verkehrswege die auf lande auf landweg
stattfinden
es gibt im moment noch gespräche auch zu
den anderen verkehrswegen aber darüber
ist bisher nicht entschieden
zur ersten frage es ist natürlich so
dass wir in einem schengen raum in einem
raum der offenen grenzen die
infrastrukturen in den vergangenen
jahrzehnten auch zurückgefahren haben
gleichwohl
tut die bundespolizei das was in ihrer
sozusagen tatsächlichen macht auch steht
also sie versucht dort zu kontrollieren
wo es möglich ist
jedenfalls gilt die anordnung der
kontrollen für die gesamten
grenzabschnitte das heißt nicht für
einzelne straßenverbindungen sondern für
alle grenzüberschreitende verkehrswege
aber es ist unrealistisch zu glauben
dass man 800 kilometer an ein deutsch
österreichische grenze sozusagen meter
für meter kontrollieren kann das ist
aber ehrlich gesagt in der sicherheit
immer so dass man maßnahmen trifft die
natürlich auch nicht hundertprozentig
flecken flächendeckend sind aber wir
gehen an die stellen ran wo kein zu
beschreibender verkehr ausgesprochen
wahrscheinlich ist und dann wird das
abgestuft haben wir jetzt die frage
haben sie 92 ministerium noch rein und
dann kommt noch mal mit der frage an das
gesundheitsministerium bitte nicht an
mich jetzt dieses also ich kommt dass
ich sehe mich interessiert ob
mittlerweile eine art härtefallfonds
plant ist um zum beispiel kommunen zu
unterstützen die dinge einstellen
absagen mussten oder große unternehmen
zu unterstützen
also wie gesagt eher mehr das paket hier
vorgestellte was wir uns an maßnahmen
vorstellen um beschäftigte und auf
unternehmen zu schützen
die länder sind sicherlich mit ihren
kommunen im gespräch was da zu tun ist
der minister hat ausdrücklich gesagt
wenn weitere notwendigkeiten sind wird
man darüber sprechen hat gestern ja auch
angekündigt weitere maßnahmen wenn
notwendig einzuleiten oder das ist der
stand der nicht mitteilen kann jetzt
viel wir bleiben sie dort im freien
steht noch infrage
auch zu dem was der minister gestern
angekündigt hat bei anne will
insbesondere der vor der dann eingesetzt
werden könnte um laufende kosten zu
refinanzieren wenn die einnahmen
wegbrechen
gibt es da schon eine vorstellung wie
hoch der fonds ist und ob das jetzt rein
auf bundesebene ist oder weil jetzt
offensichtlich die bundesländer auch
solchen fonds einrichten wie kann ich
das genaue aussehen und gibt es darüber
hinaus noch kann kann sowas auch auf
europäischer ebene eingeführt werden
der minister hat sich gestern dazu
geäußert dass die gespräche dazu laufen
sobald wir da details vorstellen können
werden wir das tun
zur europäischen ebene auch da ist
natürlich ein koordiniertes vorgehen und
ein solidarisches vorgehen erforderlich
deswegen treffen sich heute die
finanzminister der euro gruppe in einem
video call dazu wird der minister sich
sicherlich auch noch äußern und morgen
die finanzminister der gesamten der
gesamten eu auch als video call und auch
da wird sicherlich das thema corona und
krisenreaktion im mittelpunkt stehen
dann im wechsel machen zum
gesundheitsministerium und kommen dazu
herr scholl kann ich würde interessieren
erstmal die konkrete zahl der
intensivbetten in deutschland stimmt die
zahl von 28.000 im moment ich würde
interessieren wie viel von diesen 28
werden es 28.000 sind jetzt im moment
belegt sind und auf welche zahlen man
hochkommen kann im notfall also kann man
dieser stoppeln oder verdreifachen
das wäre die erste frage und die zweite
frage ist etwas vielleicht ungewöhnlich
aber ich habe heute mir noch mal die
zahlen der sterbens rate angeschaut wenn
wir eine erklärung dafür warum es in
deutschland noch im zweistelligen
bereich bewegt also und 20 glaube diesen
bereichen waren das heute früh und in
frankreich bei ähnlichen fällen das
zehnfache daran geschweige denn von von
italien und spanien
ja ich fange mit der ersten frage an das
thema intensivbetten hatten wir am
freitag schon die zahl 28.000 stammt von
der dkg und die würde ich sie auch
bitten dann zu fragen wie viele von
diesen betten jetzt freies in diesem
zusammenhang nochmal der appell des
ministers am freitag an alle
krankenhaus-geschäftsführer zu prüfen
inwieweit man die kapazitäten ausbauen
kann
der appell verschiebbare operationen zu
verschieben und auch zusätzliche
personal besetzen zu heben damit
genügend kapazitäten für intensiv
flüchtige patienten da sind zum zu ihrer
zweiten frage das können wir im moment
noch nicht auswerten also dass dazu kann
ich ihnen jetzt nicht sagen
wir haben immer gesagt wir haben ein
gutes gesundheitssystem wir haben sehr
früh getestet aber ich kann ihnen jetzt
noch nichts
noch keine valide analyse dazu liefern
gut dann gehen wir zum kollegen in der
letzten reihe gehen wann vor zur
kollegin dortmund mitte meine frage geht
auch an dieses jurack
wochenende aber an bernie minister
seehofer hatte am sonntag gesagt dass er
halb von mehreren quellen in die
regierung gehört dass es gab solche ein
übernahmeversuch von den usa aber dass
er bietet heute noch mehr darüber reden
an hat er schon miteinander gesprochen
und was hat er gelernt und auch von der
von frau adebar hat jemand von
auswärtiges amt direkt mit den
skaterpark mit geredet wurde über dieses
versuche ich kann nur noch mal
wiederholen was ich gerade gesagt habe
die bundesregierung in frage woran zu
klobig genau da habe ich keinen anderen
satz stand als meine kollegin vom
wirtschaftsministerium hat minister
seehofer mit jemand heute gesprochen er
hat gesagt am sonntag der serien mit den
mit anderer kollegen reden über dieses
fall um mehr zu wissen
also es finden dazu der gesamtthematik
um das thema corona finden ja laufend
gespräche statt
zwischen der bundeskanzlerin und
mehreren betroffenen ministern an diesen
gesprächen bin ich nicht dabei ich kann
also nicht sagen welcher beitrag der vom
bundesinnenminister kamen aber sie
können davon ausgehen dass das thema
dort besprochen worden ist wissen sie
vom welche quelle hat er gemeint er hat
gesagt dass er halb von mehreren die
regierung gehört dass das gab es ja eine
feine übernahmeversuch ich kann ihnen da
keine näheren angaben machen
ja aber ich hätte da noch ganz
euphorisch
natürlich wir sind ständig mit dem state
department im gespräch und ich glaube
die ihre meinung zu dem sachverhalt die
hat die kollegin aus dem bmwi
dargestellt und die ist ja auch durch
äußerungen auch des außenministers und
anderer kolleginnen und kollegen aus der
bundesregierung deutlich geworden die
wir dazu einnehmen
ja ich möchte direkt anschließen ich
glaube im parkour weg war es ja so dass
der mehrheitseigner des unternehmens
gesagt hat machen wir einfach nicht sie
nicken frau waren
wie verhält es sich aber wenn andere
unternehmen in ähnlicher situation
keinen mehrheits anteilseigner haben der
sagt nein wir geben diesen lockruf des
geldes dann eben doch nach verfügen sie
über ein instrumentarium um in solchen
fällen in der situation über eine sagen
wir mal restriktive exportpolitik
beschließen oder anordnungen zu können
also ich möchte hier nicht über etwaige
künftige fälle spekulieren die jetzt
nicht zur debatte stehen
unsere haltung ist klar die
bundesregierung hat ein hohes interesse
dass wir impfstoffe und wirkstoffe in
deutschland und europa produzieren dazu
gibt es ja auch verschiedene initiativen
innerhalb der bundesregierung von seiten
des bundesforschungsministeriums gibt es
da verschiedene initiativen um genau
dieses ziel voranzutreiben und daneben
gelten die immer geltenden bestimmungen
des außen- wirtschafts- rechts- der
investitions prüfung sollten die dort
genannten bedingungen erfüllt sein kann
dass eine investitions prüfung geben und
dann gibt gilt wie immer der prüf
maßstab der öffentlichen sicherheit und
ordnung ja nachfrage aber sie sagen
nicht sie wollen nicht spekulieren wir
haben ein kulturgut schutzgesetz
kulturgüter von nationaler bedeutung
nicht exportiert werden dürfen so etwas
hat ja im zweifel zwar einen höheren
rang
mich interessiert nur die frage ohne
dass es das im detail aus aufgeblättert
werden muss gibt es ein instrumentarium
mit dem sie im zweifelsfall verhindern
können dass das was die
us-administration ja offenbar versucht
hat dass das verhindert werden kann gibt
es ein solches instrumentarium diese
frage habe ich versucht zu beantworten
sagt eben verschiedene instrumente auf
diesem weg die initiativen um
forschungsgelder zu bündeln um das
voranzubringen die existieren es gibt ja
aktuelle initiativen und
wirkstoffproduktion in deutschland
voranzubringen das könnten vielleicht
die kollegen aus dem
bundesforschungsministerium dann nochmal
ergänzen und für für das die frage der
übernahmen gibt es ein extra existieren
das instrumentarium das
außenwirtschaftsrecht mit seinen
investitionsplan dann greift wenn wir
eine gefährdung der öffentlichen
sicherheit und ordnung haben aber
nochmal ich möchte ja auch nicht über
etwaige fälle spekulieren in den
jetzigen fall von kinect ist eine ganz
klare aussage
der unternehmensleitung und die haben
wir begrüßt denn impfstoffproduktion die
vorangetrieben werden muss muss für alle
verfügbar gemacht werden
frau renault und dann gehen wir waren ja
meine frage ist an frau alte herr maas
hat gesagt diese diese thema curie weg
würde an der g7 gipfel besprochen werden
und ich wollte wissen was es zu erwarten
von diesem gespräch
das ist ja ziehen also herr maas hat
dass die virtuelle konferenz der g7
außenminister gemeint die auch nächste
woche ansteht
dort wird man eben über fragen wie
kommen wir in der internationalen
zusammenarbeit zu mehr solidarität wie
finden wir gemeinsame lösungen für
herausforderungen des impfstoffes für
all die anderen internationalen
herausforderungen vor denen sie gerade
die ganze internationale gemeinschaft
stellt wie bekommen wir da
zusammenarbeit hin
insofern kann ich ihn da jetzt noch
keine ergebnisse liefern aber das ist
ein thema was auch der außenminister
dort gerne diskutieren möchte aber
vorgeschaltet gibt es glaube ich eben
auch noch das virtuelle treffen der
staats und regierungschefs auf und auch
in g7 rahmen speziell dazu genau ich
kann jetzt wie gesagt dem der video
schalte der d7 heute um 15 uhr nicht
vorgreifen aber wie auch eben schon
gesagt geht es ja genau darum also die
internationale zusammenarbeit ist bei
diesem thema natürlich von großer
bedeutung und insofern werden die stadt
den regierungschefs sich in diesem
treffen natürlich
da ihrer globalen verantwortung ganz
bewusst sein so jetzt hab ich wir geben
hier den kollegen dort dann noch mit
weiteren fragen zu dem thema sie waren
noch dran dann verdunste jung und dann
schlage ich vor
gucken wir mal ob wir das thema auch
wechseln denn es gibt auch eine ganze
reihe von fragen zu anderen themen schon
mal weiter hinten
christine ein paar berliner zeitung ich
habe mal eine frage zur arbeitsfähigkeit
der regierung wie viele verdachtsfälle
und fälle von carola virus gibt es denn
in der regierung und wie ist das jetzt
mit dem ausmaß der das home office bei
den mitarbeitern insbesondere auch
minister ich meine da hätte horst
seehofer so eine entsprechende äußerung
gemacht dass man ministerium gut auch
von zuhause leiten könnte wie sieht das
aus ich kann ihnen jetzt nicht für die
einzelnen häuser genaue zahlen nennen
aber das mobile arbeiten spielt in
diesem in dieser lage natürlich eine
große rolle
die arbeitsfähigkeit der bundesregierung
und auch der verwaltung ist zu jedem
zeitpunkt gewährleistet es gibt
pandemiepläne für die einzelnen häuser
und für die bundesregierung danach
richtet sich das aber verdachtsfälle 100
noch keine
wie gesagt ich kann ihnen zu konkreten
zahlen über verdachtsfälle oder
tatsächliche fälle hier jetzt nichts
berichten
gut dann bitte frage ans bmi in spanien
setzt die polizei unter anderem auch
drohnen ein um die maßnahmen zu
überprüfen oder auch die bevölkerung
über die maßnahmen zu informieren gibt
es auch in deutschland solche pläne
drohnen einzusetzen
also wir planen das für den
geschäftsbereich des bmi derzeit nicht
also für die bundespolizei ich kann ja
nicht für die länderpolizeien sprechen
die sind sozusagen ja eigenständig ich
weiß auch jetzt nicht ad hoc welche
länder polizeien über dieses
einsatzmittel überhaupt verfügen unter
welchen rechtlichen bedingungen ist ein
satz eingesetzt werden kann deswegen
kann ich nur für die bundespolizei
sprechen uns ist im moment kein szenario
gegenwärtig bekannt dass helfen könnte
gut das war die erste runde jetzt noch
fünf nachfragen in dieser runde als
zweite fragen und dann kommen wir zu
anderen themen sind alle gewesen herr
henke frage ans verkehrsministerium
aus baden württemberg gibt es meldungen
dass der flugverkehr dort eingestellt
werden soll in den nächsten tagen herald
hat eben schon gesagt dass über andere
verkehrswege geredet wird hier ganz
gerne von ihnen gewusst wie weit bei
ihnen lagern sind für mögliche
schließungen und ist das eine
entscheidung die eigentlich die
bundesländer für sich treffen können
oder muss das in abstimmung mit der
bundesregierung oder durch die
bundesregierung erfolgen das
flugbewegungen in einzelnen
bundesländern ganz eingestellt werden
also ganz generell würde ich da einmal
auf die maßnahmen verweisen die momentan
im flugverkehr gelten
wir haben ja dort die allgemeinverfügung
des bundesgesundheitsministeriums das
heißt welche also aus welchen ländern
müssen aussteigen karten beispielsweise
ausgefüllt werden um ihn um nach halten
zu können
wenn es verdachtsfälle gab zudem gibt es
meines wissens nach die ganz normalen
sicherheitskontrollen und ansonsten muss
man jetzt speziell mit blick auf baden
württemberg noch mal gucken ob es von
welcher art schließen denn die rede
jetzt eine also findet zum beispiel noch
caro transport stattfinden verstärkte
kontrollen statt wir hatten ja die
diskussion also ist eine schließung in
diesem sinne eine komplette schließung
oder finden beispielsweise verstärkte
kontrollen statt und wie weit sind die
überlegung auf bundesebene dass man auch
eine komplette schließung in erwägung
zieht wir sind da einen regen austausch
zum einen über den krisenstab mit dem
unter führung des
bundesgesundheitsministeriums wo er auch
die kollegen aus dem gm mit dabei sind
wir sind zudem ist der minister in
ständigem austausch mit allen vertretern
der branche mit seinen länder
verkehrsminister kollegen da fand letzte
woche die erste institutionelle sitzt
der sitzung statt
die wird in dieser woche fortgesetzt das
heißt sie sind ja in der regel aus hass
dazu und gucken sie sehen die lage ist
fluide wir sind dann steht dem austausch
untereinander eine nachfrage von vorhin
sind nach ihrer kenntnis
ärzte und krankenhäuser in deutschland
mit schutzausrüstung versorgt oder gibt
es da noch engpässe und das grüner
kabinett tagt heute in willisau zu
welchem thema und wanderungen
der schutz des medizinischen personals
ist natürlich für uns von allererster
ordnung
wie sie wissen ist das bmg mit der
schaffung der schutzausrüstung geschäft
steht also da hält sich eine ganze reihe
von ressorts mit
also wir haben ja fast eine milliarde
euro jetzt für die beschaffung von
schutzausrüstung plus beatmungsgeräte
vom bmf zur verfügung gestellt bekommen
und über die weitere verteilung wird es
ein konzept gegeben was im krisenstab
entwickelt wird und darüber hinaus das
ist auch unser appell an alle
krankenhäuser und ärzte sich auch selbst
weiter um die mannschaft von
schutzausrüstung zu bemühen
also es besteht noch einmal ich habe
ihnen das gesagt ich kann also ich wir
sind dabei zu beschaffen
gut und die die bundeskanzlerin hat sich
in der tat
angesichts der aktuellen sachlage
entschieden sich mit den zuständigen
ministerinnen und ministern zu treffen
ein solches treffen soll jetzt zweimal
die woche stattfinden
die konkrete arbeitsweise wird heute in
der ersten sitzung genau besprochen
werden heute geht es darum natürlich um
die aktuelle lage um die gerade
beschlossenen grenzkontrollen die
wirtschaftlichen folgen aber auch
mögliche massnahmen zu um die soziale
distanz um die es ja jetzt hauptsächlich
geht weiter zu besprechen also wie
kriegt man das ganze eingedämmt gebremst
naja wir sitzen wir jetzt also wenn das
gehen nicht ein gutes beispiel ist für
soziale distanz ich habe überhaupt
nichts gegen frau adebar wenn du aber es
ist eben gesünder abstand zu halten
aber dass auch festgestellt und der jung
ist ich habe eine freundin
verkehrsministerium zwei einmal zum
thema bahn und telekom
die bahn hat angekündigt dass der
regionalverkehr reduziert werden soll
besteht da nicht die gefahr dass
diejenigen die trotzdem die bahn nehmen
gefährdet sind beides jahr weniger
waggons gibt weniger bahnfahrten so dass
mehr menschen in weniger zügen kommen
was ist da der hintergedanke und zum
thema telekom internet leitungen gibt es
möglichkeiten von seiten der
bundesregierung die
kapazitätseinschränkungen die es ja für
leute die internetzugang haben gibt auf
unbestimmte zeit aufzuheben
ich fange mal mit der mit der ersten
frage an zum thema regionalverkehr main
stand heute morgen 10 uhr ist das
entgegen anderslautender meldungen hält
die deutsche bahn ihre fahrpläne in der
deutschen regionalverkehr ohne
einschränkungen aufrecht etwas anderes
gilt nur wenn die aufgabenträger der
länder über mögliche fahrplan
anpassungen entscheiden
das heißt die länder bestellen ja den
regionalverkehr bei der deutschen bahn
wenn die merken beispielsweise sie
haben strecken die vorwiegend
beispielsweise für den schulverkehr
genutzt werden sie haben dort eine
geringere nachfrage dann kann eventuell
eine eine eine umstellung beispielsweise
den sonntagsfahrplan erfolgen generell
gilt aber dass der innerdeutsche
regionalverkehr ohne einschränkungen
aufrechterhalten wird und in sachen
internet in sachen internet anmeldung
das wäre dann höchst vermutlich eine
sache die die verträge betrifft und da
wären dann die kollegen aus dem justiz
und verbraucherschutzministerin ja
vielleicht irgendein beantworten kann
ist das ministerium anwesen könnte dazu
was sagen dass beschäftigt gerade viele
leute haben angst dass sie jetzt quasi
noch zwei tagen zu hause sitzen qualität
mehr haben oder was sinnvoll ergänzen
wenn es nur darum geht zu sagen aber nix
dann würde ich sagen machen jetzt keinen
wechsel
wo es ist verbraucherschutz wir können
das so machen sie wollten ja sowieso
gleich noch etwas nachtragen
dann machen wir das dann wechseln sie
jetzt einfach denn da wir sowieso noch
eine interessante ankündigung mitteilung
vielen dank also zu ihrer frage kann ich
jetzt ergänzt wichtig gegebenfalls
nachliefern aber würde gerne ich würde
dann die gelegenheit nutzen noch eine
ankündigung zu machen wir haben vor rund
einer stunde hat das
bundesjustizministerium eine
pressemitteilung veröffentlicht
ausführlich ganze tieren wird es geht
hier um die aussetzung der
insolvenzantrags pflichten genau das der
bundesministerium der justiz und
verbraucherschutz bereitet eine
gesetzliche regelung zur aussetzung der
insolvenzantragspflicht vor im
unternehmen zu schützen die in folge der
krone epidemien eine finanzielle
schieflage geraten sind
als vorbild hierfür den regelungen die
anlässlich der hochwasserkatastrophe
2002 2013 und 2016 getroffen wurden
jetzt so erklärte bundesjustizministerin
christine lambrecht
wir wollen verhindern dass unternehmen
nur deshalb insolvenz anmelden müssen
weil die von der bundesregierung
beschlossenen hilfen nicht rechtzeitig
bei ihm ankommen
die reguläre drei-wochen-frist der
insolvenzordnung ist für diese fälle zu
kurz bemessen
deshalb lag flankieren wir das von der
bundesregierung bereits beschlossene
hilfspaket mit einer aussetzung der
insolvenzantragspflicht bis zum 30.09
2020 wird die betroffenen unternehmen
mit diesem schritt trage dazu bei die
folgen des ausbruchs für die
realwirtschaft abzufedern witz dazu
parlamentarische zustimmung
also verfahrenstechnisch wird das jetzt
so aussehen dass sich die regelungen
einfach und schnell in anlehnung an das
vorbild von 2013 in einer
formulierungshilfe zu einem noch zu
bestimmenden träger gesetz umsetzen
diese als man wird dann quasi ihr
anhängen das wäre franz technisch
möglich dabei muss das parlament
zustimmen real sein dass der bundestag
dann immer zusammenkommen kann wegen aus
quarantäne schutz gründen also wir
können überhaupt noch gesetze
beschlossen wir dazu kann nicht
sozusagen als von seiten der
bundesregierung jetzt keine keine
auskunft geben das sind ja fragen des
bundestags hierbei aber wenn der niemann
zusammenkommen kann können ja ihre
gesetzesänderungen nicht beschlossen wer
ist gut für alle frage dazu auch von
ihnen anmelden
ich würde gerne mal fällig ein
schließungen zurückkommen und zwar frage
an frau demmer gab es denn bei dieser
entscheidungsfindung gestern oder über
das wochenende meinungsverschiedenheiten
was die frage der grenzkontrollen angeht
und welches ressort beziehungsweise
welche ministerpräsident hat er auch
eine entgegengesetzte meinung vertreten
und mich würde nur interessieren
herr sei erwähnt dass jetzt am pferd
oder erste gesundheitliches personal
eingesetzt werden soll um die
bundespolizisten zu unterstützen das
eben bundespolizisten keine entscheidung
darüber treffen wenn jemand symptome
zeigt wieder mit dem verfahren wird
woher werden diese ärzte akquiriert wer
wird dafür abgestellt und eine frage
noch als bmg
es gibt unsicherheiten darüber wer jetzt
immer mehr risikogebiete ausgezeichnet
werden wer denn jetzt getestet werden
soll und wer dich gibt es dazu eine
offizielle ansage bei wem bei welchen
patienten coronas tests durchgeführt
werden soll und wer einfach nur zu hause
bleibt
ich kann vielleicht ganz schnell wurden
die bundesinnenminister hat gestern
nicht nur in abstimmung mit den
nachbarstaaten in den betroffenen
bundesländern sondern auch in abstimmung
mit der bundeskanzlerin entschieden
zu ihrer zweiten frage also die
bundespolizisten die an der grenze
kontrollen durchführen sind natürlich
nicht medizinisch geschult und auch
nicht in der lage solche diagnosen zu
treffen deswegen ist es grundsätzlich so
dass für den fall dass jemand
angetroffen wird der symptome
krankheitssymptome welcher art auch
immer jedenfalls die darauf hindeuten
könnten dass eine grippe oder eine
corona infektion vorliegt könnte solche
einschätzungen werden nur von
medizinisch geschultem personal
letztlich vorgenommen das heißt in einem
solchen fall werden die
gesundheitsbehörden hinzugezogen
und natürlich kann man in einem solchen
fall auch das ärztliche personal mit zum
einsatz bringen was die bundespolizei
selbst hat die bundes punkt zeit fügte
über sanitäts ausgebildetes personal und
die sind selbstverständlich mit im
einsatz also beispielsweise hat ja jede
dieser einsatzhundertschaften die moment
zusätzlich im einsatz ist auch ein
sanitäts druck da sind also auch
medizinische arbeitskräfte mit dabei und
auf dieser basis wird das dann gemacht
aber jedenfalls nicht durch die
polizisten allein meine frage ist ob der
öffentliche gesundheitsdienst der
sowieso im moment dadurch zusätzlich
belastet
das kann auch das kann nicht pauschal
nicht beantworten jedenfalls ist klar
dass für den fall dass jemand
festgestellt wird bei dem man davon
ausgehen muss dass möglicherweise eine
solche krankheit vorliegt dann kann man
nicht einfach sagen die einreise wird
verweigert oder
was auch immer passiert dann sondern es
muss dann sichergestellt sein dass die
notwendigen maßnahmen auch zum schutz
anderer dann eingeleitet werden und dazu
ist es notwendig dass man medizinisches
personal hinzuzieht das erfolgt auch in
der praxis zwei fragen darum und sie
haben eine frage zu dem insolvenz
gesetzen ich das richtig gesehen
zug ohne war noch eine offen ans
gesundheitsamt richtig ja ja zum thema
testern gibt es eine sehr ausführliche
empfehlung die können sie auf der
internetseite sich ansehen also getestet
werden soll beispielsweise wer symptome
zeigt und aus einem infektionsgebiet
kommt und als einem risikogebiet oder
wer kontakt hatte mit einem anderen
infizierten und so weiter da gibt es
eine ganze reihe von pfeil
konstellationen
wichtig ist aber noch zu erleben dass
ärzte diese rk ii empfehlungen
berücksichtigen sollten aber
letztendlich ist die entscheidung beim
arzt also wenn der arzt entscheidet also
hier mache ich jetzt lieber mal einen
test auch wenn es ausreichend sollte von
der rkw empfehlung wird dieser test
erstattet für bmg und frau gemma
fernando molina italien
wenn wir die geschwindigkeit der
verbreitung schauen werden wir ungefähr
in einer woche schon auf vielleicht
20.000 fälle haben sie schon eine idee
oder zumindest eine provision
über die um diese maßnahme die wir
angefangen haben zu die die betroffenen
maßnahme zu bewerten also wie viele
fälle erwarten sie in die nächste woche
ohne diese maßnahme und mit dieser
maßnahme ist zum beispiel
schulschließungen usw
danke also ich kann ganz allgemein noch
mal wiederholen dass ich eben schon
gesagt habe also grundsätzlich fachleute
bestätigen dass es in deutschland
gelungen ist das infektionsgeschehen
bereits aber einer sehr frühen phase zu
beobachten und das heißt dass wir im
augenblick ein zeitfenster haben um die
ausbreitung des virus zu verlangsamen
und die gesundheitsversorgung auch bei
erhöhten patientenzahlen so
sicherzustellen
dabei können wir auf eine ausgefeilte
fachliche expertise von den expertinnen
und experten zurückgreifen und die
bundesregierung setzt alles daran die
bevölkerung so weit wie möglich zu
schützen und deshalb werden die
maßnahmen zur eindämmung der pandemie
lage bedingt laufend angepasst
ja ich könnte nur noch ergänzen das drk
ii vizepräsident wollte er auch gesagt
hat dass wir in zehn bis zwölf tagen
sehen werden ob die maßnahmen die wir
jetzt ergreifen früchte tragen werden
die letzten zwei fragen zum thema
corinna bitte in bayern gilt ja der
katastrophenfall inwieweit kann der auch
von der bundesregierung ausgerufen
werden oder ist das ländersache und
können dann wenn sie frau der man davon
sprechen dass man immer gucken muss die
lage ist sehr dynamisch kommen eventuell
auch die notstandsgesetze die wir mal 68
hatten zum einsatz und wie viel tage hat
die bundesrepublik strategische reserven
in sachen getreide benzin und heizstoffe
wie wahrscheinlich es ist eine frage an
ein alter also ich hab ja ganz
grundsätzlich gesagt dass ich jetzt
nicht vorgreifen kann und antizipieren
können welche maßnahmen noch zu treffen
sind
grundsätzlich ist die sicherheit der
menschen zu gewährleisten dass es eben
kernaufgabe des staates
und seiner behörden der bevölkerung in
deutschland wird der bevölkerungsschutz
in deutschland liegt ja nicht in einer
hand sondern laut gesetz sind bund
länder und kommunen für die sicherheit
der menschen in deutschland zuständig
und der katastrophenschutz ist als
solcher aufgabe der länder und über
details kann sicher auch das bmi
nachrichten
ja also im wesentlichen ist das von frau
gemma schon beschrieben worden das ist
die einstufung des oder die ausrufung
des katastrophenfalls ist eine
angelegenheit die in den ländern zu
entscheiden ist
sie haben es ja angedeutet es gibt
besondere vorschriften in unserer
verfassung für den notstand und
verteidigungsfall spannungs und
verteidigungsfall heißt es glaube ich
korrekt und diese situation haben wir im
moment überhaupt nicht
gleichwohl können sie davon ausgehen
dass allein deswegen weil es diese diese
theoretische möglichkeit gibt gibt es
natürlich auch auf bundesebene
entsprechende praktische instrumente
aber nochmal im moment sind wir bei
einer situation die durch die länder zu
bewältigen ist was die
katastrophenschutz lage angeht und ich
kann im moment nicht erkennen dass der
bund eine überregionale entscheidung für
die länder treffen würde
zu den reserven die die frage die sie
gestellt haben da muss ich passen jetzt
an dieser stelle das lief ich gern
machen und dann kommen wir zum
themenwechsel
und da hatten sich schon perenne und
drei jungen und hessen gemeldet
jedenfalls wirklich gut eine stunde
haben immer noch eine frage noch mal an
ford immer heute abend findet ihr auch
noch mal eine konferenzschaltung der
eu-staatschefs statt
jetzt ist es ja so dass die maßnahmen in
europa insgesamt ja doch sehr
weitreichend sind ja auch schon
angesprochen wird auch noch mal die
wirtschaftlichen folgen ansprechen
bleibt die bundeskanzlerin bei ihrer
position dass man im moment nur
liquiditätshilfen braucht oder muss man
jetzt auch schon noch mal die diskussion
anfangen welche auswirkungen für die
volkswirtschaft in europa zu erwarten
sind und ob man da auch gegensteuern
gilt das was ich eben gesagt haben ich
kann jetzt einem einer solchen schalte
nicht vorgreifen
gut beim c am ende des themenkomplexes
corona und in der verbleibenden
vielleicht kann ich noch mal betonen
also wichtig ist natürlich die
abstimmung mit den eu-partnern die es in
dieser lage natürlich von großem
besonderer bedeutung aber die kanzlerin
das ohnehin in ständigem austausch
insbesondere mit dem staatspräsidenten
makro aber wie eben auch heute morgen
schon in der schalte mit
kommissionspräsidentin und
reichspräsident und wickeln wir und ich
habe jetzt dafür dann und schließt damit
auch die frageliste dann fragen von
herrn römer herrn jungen herrn meier
herrn hessen und dem kollegen vom rp
glaub ich fürchte dass ein
missverständliches handzeichen ich hatte
eine cola nachfrage wenn wir das thema
jetzt wechseln wollen
der wechsel ist das thema dann ist er
jung dann trotzdem noch bestimmte art
und weise eine krone zu tun aber ausland
frau adebar der iran leidet gerade
katastrophale seiten angesichts des
sanktions regimes das auch unter anderem
keine da kommen noch medizin in den iran
kommen lässt gibt es auf internationaler
ebene auf europäischer ebene bemühungen
die sanktionen gegenüber